- [Instructor] What
we're going to talk about
in this video are the origins
of the Russian people.
And in particular, we're
going to talk about
the eastern Slavs who
not just modern Russians,
but also Ukrainians and Belorussians
view as their ancestors.
So let's think about the world
in the ninth century.
The early ninth century, we
see the reign of Charlemagne
that we talk about in some
depth in other videos.
As we get into the 10th century,
you see the reign of Otto the Great,
Holy Roman Emperor over
the Germanic kingdoms.
The ninth century is also
the time of Tang China.
You have the Abbasid Muslim Caliphate
in control over most of the Middle East
and North Africa.
And it is also the Viking age.
So we have here in this magenta color,
this would be modern day Sweden,
but it was also the
home of the Varangians,
or whom we later would
refer to as the Vikings,
and we know them to be great seafarers.
In Western Europe, they're viewed
as raiders of towns along the coast.
But you have to remember, these histories
are often written by
the western Europeans,
not by the Vikings themselves.
But they were also known as traders.
What you see here are
two of the major centers
of power and trade in the ninth century.
You have Constantinople,
the capital of the Byzantine Empire,
and you have Baghdad, the capital
of the Abbasid Caliphate.
You also see these major
waterways in eastern Europe,
in particular, the Dnieper
and the Volga Rivers.
And so you have these
significant trade routes
going from the Baltic Sea
either via the Dnieper,
crossing the Black Sea
to Constantinople, or
going from the Baltic
to the Volga all the
way to the Caspian Sea
and eventually making
their way to Baghdad.
And this is well documented.
There is archeological evidence
of Viking jewelry along these routes.
There's evidence of artifacts
from these far off lands
in Viking territory, and we believe
what the Varangians traded
were first they hunted in
this area of northern Europe.
Now, the people who lived in this area
were known as the Slavs.
And there were several
broad groups of Slavs
that you will hear historians refer to.
You have the Western Slavs,
who you could view as
some of the ancestors
of modern Poles, Czechs, and Slovaks.
You have the Southern Slavs
in what would eventually be referred to
as the Balkans.
And then you have the Eastern Slavs
in what will eventually be
Russia, Belarus, and Ukraine.
Now to be clear, they
weren't unified groups.
There were many many many, for example,
Eastern Slavic tribes.
Our best account of the early history,
especially in the period as
we get into the ninth century
comes from what is known as
the Russian Primary Chronicle.
And keep in mind, this was written
at a much later period.
It was written in the early 12th century.
It is sometimes ascribed
to the Kievan monk Nestor.
So at previous times, it was
known as Nestor's Chronicles,
but we don't even have
surviving accounts of this.
We have surviving accounts
of copies of this,
or what we believe are copies of this.
What I'll share is a version
of the Russian Primary Chronicle
known as the Laurentian Text from 1377.
And this is, of course,
an English translation.
It gives us some of the earliest accounts
of the relationship between the Varangians
and the Eastern Slavs
and how what we have come
to identify as the Russian people
and the Ukrainian people
and the Belorussian people,
how they got their start.
So right before this passage,
it talks about how the
Varangians tried to get tribute
from some of the Eastern Slavic tribes.
And it says the tributaries
of the Varangians
drove them back beyond the sea
and, refusing them further tribute,
set out to govern themselves.
So they pushed them back
beyond what we now call
the Baltic Sea, and they
decided to govern themselves.
There was no law among them.
Tribe rose against tribe,
and they began to war one against another.
They said to themselves,
let us seek a prince
who may rule over us and
judge us according to the law.
They accordingly went overseas
to the Varangian Russes.
So they went back to the Russes,
and they said, these warring
Eastern Slavic tribes said,
our land is great and rich,
but there is no order in it.
Come to rule and reign over us.
They thus selected three brothers.
The oldest, Rurik, located
himself in Novgorod.
Right over here.
Novgorod literally means new town.
Gorod means town.
The district of Novgorod
became known as the land of Rus'.
So a lot of really
interesting things going on.
The Varangians, first,
are trying to get tribute
from these tribes, which is
a way of saying tax them,
making them subservient to these Vikings.
And even though these Eastern Slavs
were able to push them back,
according to the Primary Chronicle,
they said hey we need your help.
We want you to rule over us.
There's very few times in history
where people are asking a foreign group
to rule over them.
And so this is an interesting question.
Remember, this history
is written under the rule
of one of the descendants of Rurik.
So do you think it was actually this way?
Or do you think the Varangians
maybe forced themselves
on the Eastern Slavs and
later created this narrative,
that they were invited to come in?
But according to the Primary Chronicle,
we have Rurik coming from Scandinavia
to Novgorod and establishing
the land of Rus'.
Now the word Rus is really interesting.
Most historians believe
it to be the source
of what we now say Russia,
or even Belarus, which means white Rus.
Some historians think
it comes from the name
of Sweden at the time.
Some believe that the Rus
were a subgroup of Varangians,
of Vikings.
Some believe that the word is derived
from those who row.
But either way, the Primary
Chronicle goes on to tell us
from 870 to 879, on his deathbed,
Rurik bequeathed his realm to Oleg,
who belonged to his kin,
and entrusted to Oleg's
hands his son Igor,
for he was very young.
And then from 880 to
882, Oleg set himself up
as prince in Kiev and declared
that it should be the mother
of Russian cities.
So Rurik's immediate successor is Oleg.
And in the early 880s,
he goes and establishes himself in Kiev,
expanding the land of Rus'.
This is Kiev right over here,
and because Oleg was able to take Kiev,
the state that emerges from Rurik and Oleg
not only is it known as
the Land of the Rus',
but it's also known as the Kievan State,
and they're often known
as the Kievan Rus'.
And you can see here
how that state expands
over the next few hundred years.
As we get to the year 900,
you have this off-white color,
and you can see, it is in control
of both Novgorod and Kiev.
As you get to 1015, it's
taken even more territory,
and by 1113, which is near
the peak of the Kievan state,
you see that it has taken control
of a good chunk of Eastern Europe.
And as the state expands,
its character changes as well.
As you get to the end of the 10th century,
you have a major event in
one of Rurik's descendants,
Vladimir, often known
as Vladimir the Great,
he decides to convert to
Eastern Orthodox Christianity.
And in a future video, I might
talk about his rationales,
or what historians view as
his rationales for conversion.
And as we will see, over time,
and because of not only his conversion,
but essentially the conversion
of the entire Kievan state,
over time, especially
with the eventual decline
of the Byzantine Empire,
what would eventually be Russia
becomes a center of Eastern
Orthodox Christianity.
Now the Kievan state lasts
as an independent state
until we get to the 13th century.
And from many other videos,
you might be guessing what
happens in the 13th century.
You have Genghis Khan
and then his descendants
emerge out of Central and Eastern Asia,
and in 1240, you have the Mongol invasion,
at which point, many of the principalities
within the Land of Rus' become tributaries
to the Mongolians.
And they would be so for
the next, roughly, 200 years
until Ivan the Great comes along
and is able to exert
independence from the Mongols
for the Rus, but we will cover that
in a future video.